[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
die zubereitung von diesem leckeren
zahlen kuchen
den sehe ich ja immer wieder auf
instagram und dachte mir den kann man
doch sicher auch zu hause selber machen
der kuchen besteht aus einem richtig
leckeren kekse und gefüllt habe ich
ihnen mit einer mascarpone creme und
außerdem mit hübschen selbstgemachten
macarons früchten und blumen dekoriert
ihr könnt übrigens statt der zahlen auch
ganz einfach buchstaben machen oder
sogar einen ganzen namen ich zeige euch
jetzt zuallererst die zutaten für
unseren keks teil
wir benötigen mehr weiche butter
außerdem zucker und backpulver und
vanille extrakt oder vanillezucker das
backpulver geben wir mit zum mehl und
rühren das sehr gut unter
[Musik]
nun gebe ich die weiche butter in die
schüssel meiner griechen maschine
die mutter habe ich übrigens vier
stunden zuvor aus dem kühlschrank geholt
damit sie schön weich wird und dazu gebe
ich dann noch zucker und vanille extrakt
werk eine küchenmaschine hat der kann
auch ganz einfach ein handrührgerät
verwenden
[Musik]
das ganze wird dann mit dem knethaken
ein paar minuten lang hell cremig
gerührt
[Musik]
übrigens die genauen mengenangaben die
findet ihr bei mir immer unter diesem
video in der infobox
nach zwei bis drei minuten geben wir
nacheinander die eier mit hinzu und
rühren sie so lange unter bis sie sich
mit der butter masse vermengt haben
[Musik]
sobald sich dann alles miteinander
verbunden hat und dann müsst ihr auch
nicht ewig lang rühren das geht
eigentlich recht schnell geben wir die
trockenen zutaten mit hinzu also das
mehl und das backpulver das mache ich in
zwei schritten und das ganze sie mich
auch nochmal damit auch keine klümpchen
im teig entstehen
[Musik]
sobald die erste ladung mail gut
untergerührt ist geben wir die zweite
mit hinzu und lassen das noch mal so
lange kneten bis wir einen schönen tag
erhalten
wie gesagt wer keine küchenmaschine hat
der kann das ganze auch ganz einfach mit
den händen machen
[Musik]
spätestens nachdem sich der teig in der
schüssel gut verbunden hat und die
maschine auch nicht mehr weiter knetet
müssen wir das ganze auf die
arbeitsfläche geben und ganz kurz mit
den händen verkneten
an der stelle rate ich euch auch nicht
zu lange zu kneten hier braucht ihr
wirklich nur ein paar sekunden und
knetet wirklich nur so lange bis der
teig sich verbunden hat
[Musik]
den teig teile ich nun in zwei gleich
große hälften und nehme mir jeweils eine
hälfte drückte sie flach und wickle sie
in frischhaltefolie 1
[Musik]
dadurch dass der teig flach an gedrückt
wurde kühlt er etwas schneller durch und
wir gehen jetzt den teig in den
kühlschrank bis der hart wird und das
dauert meistens so drei bis
allerhöchstens vier stunden ihr könnt
diesen schritt auch gerne schon einen
abend vorher erledigen die zwischenzeit
nutze ich schon mal für die leckere
cremen wir benötigen mascarpone doppel
ram frischkäse puderzucker weiche butter
und etwas zitronensaft die mascarpone
den frischkäse und die weiche butter
geben wir jetzt in unsere rührschüssel
und auch hier wieder den hinweis werk
eine küchenmaschine hat der kann gerne
sein handrührgerät benutzen
nun wird zuerst alles mit dem
schneebesen aufsatz solange gerührt bis
sich alles miteinander verbunden hat
dann geben wir den kompletten
puderzucker mit hinzu und rühren dass
zwei minuten lang richtig schön cremig
zum schluss wird noch der zitronensaft
mit hinzugegeben und ganz kurz
untergerührt wer kein zitronengeschmack
möchte der kann an der stelle auch gerne
vanille nehmen
[Musik]
und der konsistenz her ist die
mascarpone creme nun etwas weich die
wird aber im kühlschrank noch fester und
dort lagern wir sie auch bis zur
weiterverarbeitung nach der schulzeit
geht es mit unserem keks teig weiter den
nehm ich hier aus der frischhaltefolie
und knete ihn noch mal ein paar sekunden
lang geschmeidigen
[Musik]
dann nehme ich mir einen torten retter
zu hilfe ihr könnt auch gerne ein
schneidebrett verwenden und gäbe da
etwas mehr drüber
darüber wird dann der teig ausgerollt
aber vorher nehme ich mir noch ein wenig
weg denn alles benötigen wir jetzt noch
nicht und zum ausrollen verwende ich
zwei holzstäbe die habe ich aus dem
baumarkt die sind gar nicht so teuer
und das bewegt einfach dass die kekse
alle gleich hoch werden
[Musik]
dann rolle ich dem teig aus und wichtig
ist dass ihr euch jetzt zu hilfe
ausgedruckte zahlen wo der falls ihr
buchstaben verwenden möchte auch
buchstaben nimmt und einmal kurz schaut
ob die zahl denn auch auf den teig passt
sobald ihr das einmal kontrolliert habt
gebt ihr den teig für zehn bis 15
minuten in den kühlschrank
nach dem kühlen ist der teig wieder
schön fest und ihr könnt die zahl ganz
einfach ausschneiden
[Musik]
meine zahl gebe ich jetzt auf mein mit
de bug folie ausgelegtes backblech ihr
können selbstverständlich auch ganz
normales backpapier verwenden
ihr könnt an der stelle auch noch mit
einer winkel palette nachhelfen und
sollte teuren teig dann zügig aufs
backblech legen
[Musik]
während ich weitermache wandert meinen
backblech in den kühlschrank damit der
teig auch schön kühl bleibt und mit dem
übrig gebliebenen teig schneide ich mir
jetzt gleich die zwei aus hier
kontrolliere ich auch wieder ob es drauf
passt das könnte etwas knapp werden aber
dafür gibt es tricks 17
wir schneiden uns jetzt einfach die
restlichen teig stücke aus und geben sie
auf die fehlenden stellen
[Musik]
sobald ihr die fehlenden stellen
aufgefüllt habt wandert auch dieser teig
wieder für zehn bis 15 minuten in den
kühlschrank
nach der kür zeit schneide ich die zwei
aus und gebe sie ebenfalls aufs
backblech
[Musik]
zur absoluten sicherheit gebe ich die
zwei zahlen jetzt noch mal für zehn
minuten in den kühlschrank damit sie
auch nach dem backen ihre form
beibehalten
das habe ich jetzt mit der einen hälfte
des teigs gemacht und das gleiche wieder
holen wir dann mit der zweiten hälfte
[Musik]
für die fertigstellung der torte
benötigen wir unsere kekse jeweils zwei
von ihrer ziffer außerdem früchte zum
beispiel erdbeeren himbeeren und
heidelbeeren außerdem leckere macarons
das video dazu verlinkt ich euch ein
paar schöne blumen und unsere creme
füllung zum auf spritzende creme
benötigen wir eine loch tolle welche das
ist verlinkt ich euch unten in die
infobox und jetzt beginnen wir außen
herum auf den keks unsere tupfer auf zu
spritzen
[Musik]
und anschließend wird auch die
innenfläche der kekse mit creme befüllt
[Musik]
den anderen zwei ziffern verfahren jetzt
ganz genau so und falls es bei euch in
der küche auch so warm ist dann gibt die
ziffern zur sicherheit noch mal in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
nun kommt die absolut spaßigste aufgabe
dieser torte wir geben jetzt die zwei
zahlen jeweils aufeinander und
dekorieren das ganze
[Musik]
da die leckere creme auch schön fest
wird im kühlschrank sind da auch nichts
ein
und die torte sieht jetzt schon richtig
cool aus
[Musik]
nun können wir nach herzenslust
dekorieren und ich habe mich für früchte
macarons und blumen entschieden
bei den blumen solltet ihr allerdings
aufpassen nimmt keine gespritzten blumen
und einige können auch giftig sein lasst
euch da am besten bei eurem
blumenhändler beraten
[Musik]
und somit ist die hübsche zahlen torte
auch schon fertig wie gesagt ihr könnt
auch alles andere ausschneiden aus einem
keks teig buchstaben oder sogar symbole
und der keks teig schmeckt am
allerbesten ende ein tag im kühlschrank
zieht dann wird er schön weich und den
könnt ihr euch auf der zunge zergehen
lassen falls ihr jetzt auch diesen
hübschen und mega leckeren kuchen nach
machen möchtet dann schaut gerne mal
unten in die infobox da habe ich alle
informationen für euch aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
außerdem freue ich mich wenn ihr mir ein
kostenloses abo dallas damit ihr auch
keines meiner videos mehr verpasst
abonniert mich auch gerne auf instagram
damit ihr dort immer auf dem aktuellsten
stand seit bis zum nächsten mal auf s
kitchen
[Musik]